what's going on guys this is rob and
it's been a long
time since we did the beyond omega level
series and so in this video we're going
to tackle a character that some of you
guys may be aware of but a lot of you
guys been asking for
especially after we did the video on the
spectre so long ago we're talking about
eclipso so eclipsa was first created by
bob haney and lee elias and made his
first appearance in house of secrets
number 61 in 1963. you know that's an
old comic book that's a very old comic
book i feel like i'm gonna have to buy
that old comic book you know where i'm
gonna go to buy that old comic book i'm
gonna go to hip ecommerce yes i am
okay here's the thing about hip
ecommerce i love these guys i had a
phone call with him i was talking to him
the whole idea behind hip ecommerce is
yes
it's a place where you can buy and sell
comics but their motivation is what got
me into it so basically the goal here is
to
help local comic book stores survive in
the digital age by not only selling
their stuff
in local shops but also selling it
online and the best thing about this
it was built for collectors by
collectors that's what really got me
into it because as you guys know
i collect old school comics to top all
it off they have regular auctions
and they have regular sales so you can
go on there and get some ridiculously
good deals and stuff
i went on there and bought some stuff i
loved it but make sure you guys check
out the link down in the description
make sure you go sign up for hip
ecommerce and make sure you buy some
comics but back into our video at the
time of his creation
eclipso was really not depicted as being
a major threat and he was really just a
b-list villain of the week just to give
superheroes somebody to beat up on right
you guys remember
how it was or maybe you don't remember
but you've read about how it was back in
the 1960s so originally eclipsa was the
alter ego of scientist bruce gordon who
traveled to the jungle to observe a
solar eclipse when he encountered a
sorcerer named mophir who attacked bruce
and cut him with a black diamond now the
result of this is that any time there
was an eclipse
gordon was transformed into the super
villain eclipso who had pretty generic
power super strength increased
durability and energy blast from his
eyes and he remained this way in sort of
a jekyll and hyde situation between
bruce gordon and eclipso until 1992 when
the character got his own mini-series
called the darkness within
by robert lauren fleming and keith
giffen and what this mini-series did was
drastically alter the origin and powers
of eclipso it was revealed that the
black diamond that wounded bruce
gordon in the jungle was actually a
shard of a black diamond called the
heart of darkness now in the late 1800s
the way we were told this anyway
a treasure hunter had found the black
diamond and took it to a jeweler to cut
into a thousand pieces which had the
effect
of weakening the bonds that were
trapping the soul of a demon inside
and so when bruce gordon was cut by a
shard of the heart of darkness
eclipso's soul was able to escape and
possess him and it was further revealed
that he was simply pretending to be a
somewhat lame supervillain so as not to
draw the attention of earth's
superheroes
as well as sabotage gordon's research
into solar energy as solar energy is his
primary weakness and he feared the
development of a weapon that could
harness that energy and use it against
him and so it's during this mini-series
that we learned not only that eclipso
can possess others who touch one of the
thousands shards of the black diamond
but that he can also absorb the mass and
powers of others and can also use the
anger of others to create
literal monsters now eclipso's origin
was given yet
another vision in john ostringer's
spectre series in the 1990s for those of
you guys who saw
the beyond omega level video on the
spectre this will all sound super
familiar but for those of you guys who
don't know the spectre was depicted as
the embodiment of the wrath of god but
as it turns out he was not the first to
hold that position and in fact he took
it over from eclipso meaning that
eclipso was in fact
divine in origin now once dc launched
the new 52 in 2011
eclipso's origin was completely
retconned but because this is not the
version of the character that's most
powerful we're not going to focus on his
character in this video but
basically his whole origin is tied to
gem world instead of being a divine
being yeah
it sucks you're not wrong for believing
that it does but as for cubs those
powers they are
really quite vast like i said earlier he
possesses superhuman strength as well as
superhuman speed and stamina he's
practically
invulnerable to damage and being divine
in nature is effectively immortal he
possesses the power of flight and can
produce
powerful energy blasts from his eyes but
each of his eyes actually emits a
different
sort of energy his left eye produces
rays of dark light that are fatal to its
victims and the black light from his
right eye paralyzes opponents when it
passes through a shard of the black
diamond now klypso is also able to
possess others and when doing so he's
able to manipulate their emotions
memories and powers he can augment their
existing powers or even grant them new
powers now while this ability was
originally limited to only individuals
who physically touched a shard of the
heart of darkness
it was later made clear that eclipso's
possession powers work
even when he's far away from them
eclipso was able to corrupt the
individuals he possesses making their
darkest thoughts and desires
too strong to resist and can even alter
their physical appearance
as he did with hawkman and commissioner
gordon in the darkness within
many series now his ability to possess
others extends to extremely powerful and
intelligent individuals as well
as he possessed batman shazam and
superman during that event
now there have been more than one
instance in which eclipso has
demonstrated abilities that are beyond
omega level for instance
one of eclipso's powers is his ability
to absorb the mass and powers of others
and he was able to do this to the
spectre
and so if you're familiar with the
spectre at all you'll know that he's one
of the most powerful characters in dc
comics so for klipso to be able to
absorb his powers
definitely gives him the potential to be
beyond omega level since the spectrum
himself is well beyond
omega level in that way now on one
occasion calypso used his vast power
to control the very forces of nature and
caused a solar eclipse that shrouded the
entire world in darkness
obviously the ability to cut off the
earth from its light source for an
extended period of time
could make the entire planet
uninhabitable meaning eclipso is a
potential planetary threat and on a very
famous occasion probably the most famous
occasion eclipso
almost did destroy all life on earth as
it was actually him that was responsible
for the great flood
as in like the flood from the bible that
we get in noah's ark story and so
eclipso
acting as the embodiment of god's wrath
at that time sought to punish mankind
for their evil deeds so he sent a flood
that covered the entire world
and killed everyone but the people on
that arc so
because we know eclipso can wield divine
powers efficient enough to destroy a
world we can comfortably place him
in the omega level or beyond omega level
tier but let me know what you guys think
down below let me know in the comments
section what characters you guys want to
see
covered in future series make sure you
guys check out hip ecommerce
and i will catch you all later peace